yeah i mean if it feels like there's a
lot of people who want to you know who
have a point on the map that they want
to get to and then they have to figure
out how to get to there but really
everyone should just
move from where they are today right the
team i think that's what's so important
about the tinkering thing is it's very
important yeah exactly all all three of
us up here are tinkerers like i you know
was early on tinkering with twitter for
philosophy
um you know you sahil you're tinkering
with gumroad and like the weird way that
you run it uh you're tinkering on the
crowdfunding side you were tinkering and
rolling funds i was tinkering on how to
mechanize angel investing in vc
i was kind of opening things up with the
blogs on venture hacks and that was
tinkering ben you were tinkering on
strategy and dithering like we're
tinkerers right and i think most
successful creators are ultimately
tinkerers they're just kind of playing
around at the edges of their field on
something that is interesting to them
it's not really with some strong motive
it's play it's not really with a motive
to like create something great out of
its because they're they're genuinely
interested and most tinkering is wasted
it's like when your kids are playing
most that time is you know quote unquote
wasted but once in a while it will
result in something which for a child
might be a hobby and for an adult it
might be a vocation yeah i think it's
also inherently low status right i think
you you you kind of spend years not
making any money and maybe not building
an audience and getting really good at a
skill but you don't have any any any way
to know if you know if that's actually
going to turn into anything
uh this sort of turning into something
is you know kind of happens all at once
10 years later
well then there's something too about
learning how to be in your particular
moment
and people get so fixed full five ten
years in the future particularly when it
comes to their career
and the real danger is you end up like
succeeding and then you ended up in a
place that's just not very relevant or
interesting or there's a ton of
competition
and
i look back like how i ended up what i'm
doing and
john said that they had the quote you
know you look backwards you connect the
doc
learning i was you know maximizing
whatever i was doing at that particular
time that's what pays off and you see so
many people get so distracted about
where they want to go
and they don't take full advantage of
the spot that they're in
and then you look backwards like man i
wish i would have spent that time better
because i could have really used that
experience and it's already too late
you certainly don't want to
plan for trying to predict too much in
the future like i think the worst title
you can possibly have in your bio is
futurist
first of all it's just tone deaf but
when someone says futurist and it's like
uh you know they're trying too hard
they're trying too hard to live in the
future when yes you're right your only
moment of power and knowledge is the
present you just act from the present
it's not to say you shouldn't have like
goals and plans and those kinds of
things it's kind of nice to have them
loosely held but if you stick too
closely to them you'll miss reality
reality is very fluid and very complex
and it's much more about navigating from
the small set of options presented to
you much more choose your own adventure
style than you know top down soviet
style planning with five year plans and
i'm going to get to aid and beep and see
no i think the other thing with that too
you do need a long-term goal but that
gives you a way to think about the
immediate term options right like so i
have three options today
that are not my long-term goal i know
the general direction i'm going so i can
choose this one that maybe is
sub-optimal or maybe seems further but
i'm building up a particular skill or
getting a particular sort of experience
that will get me closer to that
long-term goal without having yeah like
a five-year plan i think that's the
exact like the exact wrong way to go
about it
well i think it's it's what's so
difficult when you when someone asks
someone who's successful like why did
you become successful and it basically
forces i feel like the person to lie
because you you look back connect the
dots and then you can't help but sort of
believe that it was it sort of happened
on purpose and that you sort of had you
know you can't remember what it was like
to not know where you were going
yeah first i picked sperm number three
billion seven hundred sixty eight
thousand four hundred twelve that then
routed its way to egg number fourteen on
the exact date of blah blah blah right
no so it's funny
oh sorry
oh no i i it was funny i told this story
on on this week's exponent exactly where
it's hilarious that i'm known as the
newsletter guy
because i
it was a total accident where i had the
i had the vision to have a subscription
base
fund was all website-centric and it was
a total disaster i i actually watched it
on thursday
it was a total mess i tore it over the
weekend i told people like look i just
screwed up the website
style for anyone's not a subscriber i
it's the wrong direction i'm just going
to email you if you subscribe i'll email
you additional stuff in addition to the
website
it's like literally like a spur of the
moment i have to fix this problem figure
it out how am i going to get content to
my subscribers without having a bad
experience for non-subscribers and then
now today on the newsletter guy it's
like so they're when you look backwards
if you're actually honest about it
there's a lot of luck for certain a lot
of like just in the right place
it's funny angelus has a similar story
because uh first there was a network for
sharing deal flow that nivea and i built
or mostly navy built called the pound
deal flow network was literally a little
social network with a feed and you could
follow people and nobody used it and
then he built a google group and nobody
used that either and then finally we're
like screw it where this nut is working
just freaking email them the data and
that was angel list
so first let's take on big meaningful
projects
our generation is going to have to deal
with tens of millions of jobs replaced
by automation like self-driving cars and
trucks
but we have the potential to do so much
more than that
every generation has its defining works
more than 300 000 people worked to put
that man on the moon including that
janitor
millions of volunteers immunized
children around the world against polio
and millions of more people built the
hoover dam and other great projects
and now it's our generation's turn to do
great things
now i know maybe you're thinking i don't
know how to build a dam
i don't know how to get a million people
involved in anything
well
let me tell you a secret
no one does when they begin
ideas don't come out fully formed
they only become clear as you work on
them
you just have to get started
if i had to know everything about
connecting people before i got started
i never would have built facebook
movies and pop culture just get this all
wrong
the idea of a single eureka moment is a
dangerous lie it makes us feel
inadequate because we feel like we
haven't had ours yet
and it prevents people with seeds of
good ideas from ever getting started in
the first place
oh
[Music]
you